[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHARITY WORRELL: So thank
you for coming today.
What I loved most in the
book is how authentic
and how vulnerable
you were, which
I feel like when someone's
writing about their life
they don't always want to
write about the scary or sad
or other parts of it.
And I liked that you went
fair with us in the book.
So why did you decide to
take that kind of route
and not make it be all
like roses and fairy tales?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Roses and
fairy tales are not real life
and it's boring.
It was scary to
make the decision
to be so open and vulnerable.
But I just feel like it's
the only way people relate.
And it's something I discovered
a long time ago on a spin bike.
And I started to talk about
personal things up there.
I wouldn't make it subjective.
I would say things in a way that
it would apply to everybody.
And everyone would immediately
relate to what I was saying,
and get a lot out of it and
know that all the challenges
that we face every
day, we're not alone,
that we're all
facing them together.
CHARITY WORRELL: What made
you ready to write the memoir?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So a lot of
people throughout the years
always would say to me--
they would hear my story
and they would say,
you really need to write a book.
And I would just say, oh, yeah.
Never thinking it
would ever happen.
And it really just took one
person who said the same thing
and then I said yeah, yeah,
and kind of dismissed it.
And he said, no, no, you
really need to write a book
and I'm going to introduce
you to a literary agent.
And basically pulled
me, and held my hand,
and took me to meet this couple.
And they are literary agents.
And I sat in their living
room and they said,
tell me your story, and I did.
And by the time I got home,
I had a contract in my inbox.
So that's how it happened.
CHARITY WORRELL: And what made
you-- the way you wrote it,
I really liked it.
You shared personal
things and you also
made it about how you started
two businesses and all
the lessons that
you learned in it.
And then you split it into three
parts, which were reinvention,
rejuvenation, and rewards.
Why did you decide to
break it into these parts,
and make it a personal
thing and then
also throw in the business
aspect and lessons
that you learned?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I think that--
well, first of all,
the reinvention piece
is a huge part of
the story, which
is why I devoted a whole
section to it, because I
have had a lot of
roadblocks along the way.
It was not an easy
ride by any means
to get to being the
co-founder of both businesses.
But I wanted people to know
and understand and be inspired,
because no matter
where we are in life,
we do all have the ability
to reinvent ourselves
if we want to.
And I started SoulCycle
when I was 48.
And I started Flywheel
when I was 52.
So a lot of people
are shocked at that
and they can't even
imagine starting
a business at those ages.
But I wanted to tell
the story and let people
know that anything's possible.
So rejuvenation came from
just that starting over again.
Starting over again
after you've been
burned, or hurt, or
blindsided, and knowing
that you can pick yourself
up and start again.
And what was the last part?
Rewards.
CHARITY WORRELL: Rewards.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
I mean, obviously, for
me, it was just about--
as I say in the
subtitle of the book--
it was just about reaping
rewards from this career
that I made for myself
never ever fathoming
that I would be here today.
Never went to business school.
Didn't have a clue about
how to run a business.
And really it just
literally all came out
of following my passion.
CHARITY WORRELL: And
you started as a dancer.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I did.
CHARITY WORRELL: And then
from there something difficult
happened in life-- which I want
everyone to read the book--
I'm not going to
give everything away.
You went through something
difficult and that's kind
of how you found spin.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
It's interesting
because no matter
what you do in life and--
whether you were a musician or a
dancer or anything growing up--
and no matter what
path your career takes,
it's so interesting
in retrospect,
what you bring to your career
that you might have learned
when you were eight years old.
And so for me, we were talking
about this today, with dancing,
I was constantly
in a dance class.
And I saw how gratifying it
was if the dance teacher said,
great job, Ruth,
or beautiful, Ruth.
And that could just
make my entire day.
And that's just an
example of something
that I brought to
the spin class.
Because as I said we were
talking about, if someone says,
great job, Charity,
that's all you need.
And it gives you almost a
high for the rest of the day.
And so that was just
one small component
of this product that came to
be where at the end of the day
people felt better about
themselves after 45 minutes.
CHARITY WORRELL: So how is your
method different than the--
when you started
taking spin at--
was it a Reebok?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: The Reebok Club.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
So is your method the
instructor that you
fell in love with there,
that really motivated you
and kept you coming back,
or is it kind of your own
on top of that?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Well, it
started with the method
of the instructor
who became my guru.
And we were also talking
about that phenomenon
where you go to
an exercise class
and you just really become
obsessed with one instructor.
And I did with this
particular instructor.
And two years in, he got up
in front of the class one day
and announced that he
was moving to Florida.
And I was like, what?
How am I going to even
continue with my life?
And that was the
moment when I decided
I was just going
to start teaching,
because I didn't like any
of the other instructors.
And I had a background,
obviously, in dance.
And I had taught some
group exercise before that.
So I started teaching.
And then my five years
of teaching at Reebok
is when I really
honed my method,
and added on to what he
taught me, and really spent
the time observing
what people liked,
what they didn't like, what they
took to, what motivated them.
And those were really the
formative years of my class.
CHARITY WORRELL: And then from
there you formed SoulCycle.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I did.
CHARITY WORRELL: With
Elizabeth and Julie.
And how long did that take
from the thought of you
guys wanting to have a
spin class of your own,
because you noticed
that people that
were going into Reebok to take
spin were only taking spin--
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Exactly.
CHARITY WORRELL:
--that you wanted to--
you guys, I feel like,
were the pioneers
of this boutique fitness.
So you wanted to start
this from like when
you thought of it
to how long did
it take to come off the ground?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So the fall of
2005, Elizabeth approached me.
She was a rider in my class.
And said, I want to open up
a dedicated boutique fitness
studio that only has spin.
And are you interested?
I know nothing about spin.
I would love you to be
the face of the business,
and have it be all about your
method, and the way you teach.
And what do you think?
And I mean, within a
nanosecond I was like I'm in.
It was a dream of mine.
I didn't have the
capital to fund it.
She did.
And so that was in the fall.
And then eventually, Julie, who
was also a rider in my class,
was always interested in
opening a spin business
and she and I used to talk
about it all the time,
but neither one of us
had the money to do it.
So I am a very loyal
person, and I felt bad
that it was Elizabeth and
I, and there was Julie.
So I introduced
Julie to Elizabeth
thinking she'd be a
great third partner.
And they hit it off.
And in answer to
your question, we
started really formulating our
ideas in probably December,
and we opened our
doors in April of 2006.
CHARITY WORRELL: Wow.
That's pretty fast.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So not that long.
CHARITY WORRELL: And then
it built momentum and then
there was a dissolution
of partnership.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Correct.
CHARITY WORRELL: And
you still taught there
for a couple of years after.
And then you were approached
by two other riders.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
CHARITY WORRELL:
And then Flywheel
was born, which I'm
very happy about.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
Thank you.
CHARITY WORRELL:
I love Flywheel.
So how did that--
leaving SoulCycle to
go found a competitor--
how did that happen?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So with the way
things went down at SoulCycle,
I was very ready to leave.
And I met, as you said, one
of my future co-founders
who was in my class.
[CLEARS THROAT] Excuse me.
The other one, he
never took class--
CHARITY WORRELL: No.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: --but
he was his partner--
they were both in
private equity.
And basically, they saw
this business in SoulCycle,
and saw the throngs
of people coming in,
and sat and crunched
the numbers one day,
and said this is
a real business,
and wanted to get in on it.
And so Jay-- one of them--
he is the one that came up
with the idea of attaching
a little computer
screen to all the bikes
where you can be
accountable, where you could
know where your
resistance should be,
what your speed should be.
And they found me and
presented this idea to me.
And initially, I
was a little dubious
because I thought
so much of my ride
was about riding,
closing your eyes,
going inside, tapping
into what was going on,
tapping into the song on
the playlist, a memory
or whatever it was.
And I thought, well, now if
we have numbers, I don't know.
It's distracting.
And then we can't really
do the mind thing.
And so I wasn't really sure.
And they said,
well, just try it.
Go into a room by
yourself with the bike
and see what you think.
And that's what I did.
And within 15 minutes I
was like this is genius.
And the other thing that was so
exciting about it was it just
became such an
obvious differentiator
between what was to become
Flywheel and SoulCycle.
So here we were starting
second in the market,
but it was such a
different product
that I absolutely knew
there would be room for it.
CHARITY WORRELL: So how
was it trying to, I guess,
change your teaching
method, because SoulCycle
is so different than Flywheel.
Was it more difficult when you
had to add in metrics and teach
by numbers?
And did that affect
how you taught at all?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: It
definitely changed the class
that I had started at SoulCycle.
But I was able to
still incorporate
some mind body connection
stuff with the metrics.
And I so quickly realized
that it was such a game
changer in terms of, as I
said, being accountable.
And then what happened was
I started seeing the results
in people's bodies, in
their joy and gratification
that they got from
this kind of class
with these kind of
real-time results.
And so I was a fan
from the get-go.
CHARITY WORRELL:
I read an article
that said the difference
between people
that ride at
SoulCycle and Flywheel
are that Flywheel
people are masochists.
[LAUGHTER]
I was like me.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Interesting.
I know some masochists
at SoulCycle.
CHARITY WORRELL: I just
feel like it's very type
A. It's very competitive.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: It absolutely is.
CHARITY WORRELL: You
have a leaderboard.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
It's very competitive.
CHARITY WORRELL: It's definitely
why I'm a huge fan of it.
So how do you pick
your playlist?
Is it just your mood or is it
based on the numbers we get
in class?
Or how do you decide?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: It's
so instinctual.
Music has always been a
really huge part of my life,
especially being a dancer.
Growing up, I don't know
music was my escape.
I had a kind of very
difficult mother,
which I talk about in the book.
And when things got tough,
I would go in my room
and listen to music.
And I ended up really learning
a lot about all different kinds
of genres of music through
my father and the music that
was always played in my
household growing up,
and dancing, obviously.
And so making the playlist
was such a huge part
of my enjoyment in what I do.
I spend an enormous amount
of time making my playlists--
too much time--
but I love it.
And so very mood-driven.
I would typically make
a playlist for my class
the night before.
And then I would wake
up in the morning
and leave myself time,
because I would completely
change it the next morning.
So again, way too
much time spent on it.
But it ended up bringing
very successful playlists
that people really liked.
And making them eclectic
was really important too.
So hopefully,
there was something
for everyone in the class.
CHARITY WORRELL: So
then you had Flywheel.
And you and David and
Jay were cranking along
and it started to
become successful.
And then Lew Frankfort
became a series B investor.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yeah.
Series C, actually.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Series C, oh, OK.
How did that change
the dynamics of when
it was the start-ups to then
becoming a bigger brand?
How did that change--
did it change
how you taught or the
dynamics of the relationships
within that you had with the
instructors or in general?
Because I know when Google--
obviously, I've heard people
talk about when they were here
before--
it became public-- the
difference in the culture
then when you become this giant
company, which Flywheel now is.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
Huge change.
Lew initially became a
strategic investor-- series C.
And when that
happened, the change
wasn't felt that obviously,
because we were all there.
David and Jay were there.
And we were still--
Lew had input on decisions--
but we were still
making most of the decisions.
It wasn't until 2014
when Lew and his family
acquired the business that
things really changed.
So within the first two months,
my two co-founders were out.
And that in itself was a
huge adjustment for me.
And just the culture
changed drastically.
Suddenly-- I mean, my original
office that I shared with Jay
was an electrical closet.
And I mean, we couldn't
even back up our chairs
without hitting each other.
But it didn't matter.
We didn't care.
And then this happened,
the company was acquired,
and suddenly we're in offices
that are a city block long.
And the whole culture
changed in that it just
became much more corporate.
So I suddenly was
in this environment
where I didn't even
understand the language.
It was like I'd be at
a meeting and they'd
ask us to turn in our--
hold on-- our strategic
operative initiatives.
And I'd be like, what?
I had no idea what they
were talking about.
And then someone
whispered to me,
it just means what's your plan.
And then I felt, well,
why don't they say that?
It was just such a shock for me.
And it was a real
growing experience,
which we talked about too.
CHARITY WORRELL: So what
was it like, I guess, when--
after Lew took over--
you did talk about
in the book that--
I'm trying to frame
this correctly.
Not that you were
trying to be forced
into a different position,
but the expectations
of what your role were
to be had changed.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
CHARITY WORRELL: And where
you really enjoyed teaching,
you were now pushed
in this business role
and that didn't
really make you happy.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Correct.
I found the whole--
I found all the changes
to be intimidating,
because it was just
out of my comfort zone.
And right from the get-go,
Lew wanted to mold me
in a very different way.
And suddenly my days were spent
in meetings after meetings.
And a lot of talking and ideas.
But ideas that weren't
necessarily being executed.
But we would just keep
having more meetings.
And I went into this business
exactly for the exact reason
that I didn't want to be
sitting in a meeting all day.
And so it just became
really difficult.
And I just stood
up one day and I
said this isn't working for me.
And I had no idea how
they were going to react.
But clearly, they needed me.
So they were open to
what I had to say.
And through that
process, I really
ended up going
back to what I did
best, which was being in charge
of everything that went on
in the four walls of the studio.
And training instructors,
teaching classes,
being back in charge
of the method,
and all things creative.
That was my happy place.
So I did, through a series
of events, get back there.
CHARITY WORRELL:
So the other focus
on the book that I really
liked was you, again,
talked about a lot
of personal things.
The relationship that
you had with your mother
and your father.
That was kind of a triangle.
This triangle theme I
noticed a lot in the book.
So it goes from your
mother to your father.
Then with your
husband and Felipe.
Then Julie and Elizabeth.
Then David and Jay.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Keep going.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARITY WORRELL: And
then your twin daughters.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
It never ends.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARITY WORRELL: Have
you noticed this a lot
when you're attracted
to certain situations,
if there's some kind
of trio that happens.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Apparently,
that is what happens.
And as I also talk
about in the book,
I started therapy a long
time ago when I was 35.
And I'm 60.
I'll be 61 in March.
So I've had a lot of years in
terms of learning about myself.
And I certainly am more aware
than ever of the triangles
and really hope I
don't have any more.
Really hope so.
CHARITY WORRELL:
What I really enjoyed
is you definitely were
not afraid to talk
about uncomfortable things and
how you reinvented yourself.
And really how at any
age you can do that.
If you're unhappy with
something, you can change it.
And if you're passionate about
something, if you follow that,
things will just kind of
fall into place, which I felt
like happened a lot with you.
Do you have any advice
for other entrepreneurs
who are looking to
start a business?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I do.
I think we all want
to do that now.
We all want to be
entrepreneurs and come up
with the next great idea.
And this concept of finding your
passion is spoken about a lot.
And I always like to tell people
that you just don't sit down
one day and find your passion.
And sometimes it comes to
you when you least expect it.
And after I gave up dancing,
which had been my passion,
my whole life, starting
from age eight,
I never in a million
years thought
I would ever be passionate
about something else.
And the reason why I
found spin was really
because through a
lot of years I just
tried to be open to all
kinds of experiences.
And a lot of those
experiences were negative
and didn't work for me.
I tried to work in an
office as an office manager
at a catering company, because
I was interested in food.
I did that after
I gave up dancing,
because I had no idea
what I was going to do.
And you know what,
I hated it, and I
learned that I don't
want to sit at a desk.
So that was informative.
As I was going through
the trauma of my divorce,
that's when I found spinning.
And I decided one day,
again, to just head
into that kind of
intimidating feeling--
spin room at the
gym I belonged to--
after several weeks of
walking back and forth
and should I or shouldn't I.
And one day, I don't know,
something in me said, oh,
just go in there and try it.
And I did.
And that was when
I found spinning.
But there was a lot in between.
And so I just think it's
important to have faith
and know that you will find it.
And it might not happen
when you expect it to.
CHARITY WORRELL: So you
recently left Flywheel.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I did.
Very recently.
CHARITY WORRELL: Which
I saw in December.
What are you most
excited to get into next
or is it just kind
of open-ended?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Big breath.
So I'm in my
non-compete period now,
so I can't really talk
about what's next.
And I don't know
definitively what it is.
I'm trying to--
right now my process
is about having actually
lots of meetings
with different kinds of people,
and figuring out what people
want, what people still desire.
We're in this age of everything
going digital, obviously,
and people working
out by themselves
in their home, which is really
kind of the opposite of what
I've always done.
And so I'm gathering
a lot of information
about how much of a desire
is there still for the group
experience, and
working out together,
and building a community?
Studying trends right
now and letting that help
me get to that next decision.
So I really don't
know yet, but it
will be in fitness, of course,
because that's what I do best.
And we'll see.
It's exciting.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Touching on that
a little bit about
working out at home,
I read in the book
that the owner
or the person that
invented Peloton--
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
CHARITY WORRELL: --approached
you guys about partnering.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: He did.
CHARITY WORRELL: And was it Lew
that didn't want to go for it?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: It was.
CHARITY WORRELL: Wow.
Interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, missed opportunity.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yeah,
he specifically
said if we're going to
get into that business,
we'll do it ourselves.
And that was his belief.
CHARITY WORRELL: What are
your feelings on the working
out alone, having the
interactive class as
opposed to being in the room?
I mean, I know how
I feel about it.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yeah.
Look, I feel like
obviously it was
a great opportunity for John.
He's done incredibly well.
The company is
valued at $4 billion,
I think, at this point.
CHARITY WORRELL: Now
they're adding treading.
I just saw--
RUTH ZUKERMAN: They have a
treadmill component as well.
So obviously, there's a market
for it and a need for it.
I still firmly
believe that there
are enough people out there
who want the group experience.
And truthfully, so much of
the success of both SoulCycle
and Flywheel was the building
of this exceptional community.
And the community
obviously consists
of people sharing in
this experience together.
And personally, and
I could be wrong,
I just feel that in this day and
age of so much disconnection,
and working out alone or
being on our phones all day,
I feel like human connection
will never really go out
of style.
And I think it's always
an innate need for us.
And I feel for
that reason, there
will always be a market
and enough people
out there who want
to go back to that.
And I feel that--
I'm just going to say it--
I feel like in this
huge expansion that
occurred for Flywheel
and SoulCycle,
I think a lot of that got lost.
A lot of the community and that
high touch customer service.
And so I feel like there
is a need to bring it back.
And I do think that
things go in full circles.
So I'm thinking
a lot about that.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
I definitely think that
there's a lot more energy
that you get when
you're physically
in the class than
working out at home.
I just, personally for
me, I'm more accountable
when I have people around me
than it's just me by myself.
And I think a great
instructor also motivates you
when you're physically
looking at them,
and they call out your
name, like we talked about.
it motivates you to push
even more to really get
in the uncomfortable place.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Right,
because it's the connection
you have with the instructor.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah,
and you will go very far
for that one instructor.
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes
CHARITY WORRELL: It's amazing.
It's amazing that I feel
your brand or brands,
because SoulCycle is like that--
I know really
popular instructors,
their classes will book up
the second that it opens.
And people will pay extra
to have the early booking
for that reason.
And I feel like Flywheel is just
a different kind of experience.
And it's more
motivating to me when
I have a really good
instructor, that
keeps me accountable
physically in class
than I would by myself at home.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I agree.
I get it.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
So onto some fun stuff now.
In the book, you
talk about being
able to travel more after
your children were older
and you guys have trips
that you take together.
And how much you
love to eat, which
is also why you enjoy
working out so much.
What has been your--
obviously, I'm
really into food--
we talked about this as well.
What has been your most
favorite food experience?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Hmm,
I mean, I'm not
sure there was a specific one.
But because my
partner and I were
both equally into eating good
food, literally every business
trip we would take, the
first thing we would do
is check out the best
restaurants in whatever city
we went to.
So it was great.
So I had great
dining experiences
in every city I went to.
Yeah, I mean, the whole
premise of Flywheel,
because of he and I, was all
about working hard, playing
hard.
And we were never
about deprivation
or cut out this, cut
out that from your diet.
It was all about eating
whatever you want,
drinking, and just working
out hard on the Flywheel
bike the next day.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Being accountable.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: And
that was our mantra.
Yeah, I mean, it was one of
the reasons why traveling
was so much fun
is because we got
to experience so many
different kinds of restaurants.
CHARITY WORRELL: When you
were a part of Flywheel still
and you were looking
for instructors,
was there some kind
of personality trait
or what struck you about who
you wanted to bring in to teach?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: We
certainly hired instructors
who liked to work hard.
And motivate that way by being,
as we said, aspirational.
That was our word when we were
looking for an instructor.
They had to be
aspirational, whether it
was because of their
own physical prowess,
or a certain X factor that
was so important-- that
is so important in
every instructor--
and that was actually a
part of the personality that
was really hard to train.
They kind of either had to have
it or they weren't hireable.
So again, some dynamic
in their personality
that could draw a rider in on
top of their physical strength.
CHARITY WORRELL: Now, I know
that Flywheel recently--
maybe in the past couple
of years-- added--
I think it was previously
called Fly Beats,
now it's called Tempo.
And that is similar-ish
to SoulCycle,
but it just has a little more
resistance than SoulCycle does.
Is that the reason
you added that
in for people who were more
drawn to that kind of method,
but also wanted the
metrics to go with it?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So that was a
really interesting learning
lesson.
And the reason is,
yes, we decided
to add it because it was more
about a rhythm ride, which
is how the SoulCycle
ride is based.
And we thought, well,
we should add it
and then we can cast our
net wider, and hopefully,
draw on some of those
riders who specifically
like that kind of ride.
What I realized in retrospect
was I regretted it,
because I feel like,
do what you do well,
and really represent
the specialness
of your product and your ride.
And don't feel that you
have to get everyone.
There are enough people
out there, especially
in big urban cities--
New York, obviously-- there
are enough people out there
to fill your rooms.
And why not just really
stick to what you do best?
And it just started
to dilute the product.
And I wasn't really
crazy about the idea,
to be honest with you.
CHARITY WORRELL:
How did you decide
which locations you would
add it in to try it out?
Just the bigger cities?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Our
initial way of identifying
locations was just open
next to a Whole Foods.
[LAUGHTER]
It really was.
That was our formula--
open next to a Whole Foods.
And it always worked.
[LAUGHTER]
We did mostly
choose urban areas.
We did, however--
what we would do
is we'd find an urban area,
a spot next to a Whole Foods,
and then we would
open in a suburb close
to the initial studio.
So that we could
format our instructors
and they could actually
teach at both locations.
And it was a great way to
utilize our instructor team.
So we did add suburban
locations as well.
There were exceptions, but some
did really well, some didn't.
We just found the formula of--
we found it much safer
to open in urban areas
more than suburban areas.
And I think that for some
reason in suburban areas,
even if they were
wealthy areas, people
didn't want to spend money as
much as they do in the city.
And that was an interesting
learning experience as well.
I was just going to say when--
I just thought of this--
when we opened in Scarsdale,
for example, I didn't
think about the fact that--
and I learned this from
our Scarsdale riders--
they would say to
me, we don't want
to pay New York prices, that's
why we moved to Scarsdale.
And it was like, oh,
that makes sense.
So they would
complain all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARITY WORRELL: What has been
your most favorite experience
that you've been
able to do because
of Flywheel or in SoulCycle?
Like something that
you were like, wow,
I can't believe
this is happening.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Writing the book.
I never in a million
years thought
I would ever be an author.
But ironically-- and this is
kind of consistent with staying
open to things--
when I went through my divorce.
And I was really a
fish out of water.
I had no idea what I was
going to do with my life.
And I decided to take a
course in memoir writing--
completely randomly.
I knew that I always
liked to write,
but just thought,
oh, that'll be fun.
And so I never, again,
in a million years,
thought I would ever
write a book or a memoir.
But maybe that
was foreshadowing.
I don't know.
CHARITY WORRELL: Thank
you so much for coming.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: You're welcome.
Thank you for having me.
CHARITY WORRELL: It's literally
have been such a great time
talking with you today.
I'm going to open it
up for questions now.
If people want to walk
up to the microphones.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
Huge Flywheel fan.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Thank you.
Yay!
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I'd love to hear
more about the relationship
dynamics of your co-founders
at SoulCycle, because it
sounds like you were approached
by one, and that had
brought the other one in,
and then you wound
up out of the mix.
And having founded a startup
where we had a co-founder
breakup over time, I'm just
interested to learn how did
you--
what were the things that--
what went wrong and
what were the things
you were looking
for the next time
when you started into Flywheel
and maybe even moving on now?
Like what are some of the
things that are top of mind
as you think about
your next venture?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Great question.
I have to be a little careful
about what exactly happened
on that day at SoulCycle.
But in retrospect, I've
really learned a lot
about the dynamic that
the three of us had
and the mistakes that
were made on my part.
And it's been such a
growing experience for me,
learning through these mistakes.
And as I talk about in the book,
and as Charity so aptly pointed
out, the whole triangle thing
which started with my parents
really was replicated in
that business partnership.
And I ended up being comfortable
in a role that unfortunately
was comfortable
for me, which was
a role of taking the backseat,
being overpowered, being
what felt like bullied.
And quite frankly, not being
strong enough at various points
of my time at SoulCycle--
not being strong enough
to stand up for myself.
And ultimately, it
worked against me.
And I certainly had a lot
of learning experiences
to bring to my next
partnership at Flywheel
that was drastically different.
So as I talk about that
question in the book,
it's really about self-awareness
and doing the work
to get to know yourself,
however that work plays out,
and not repeating patterns and
not making the same mistakes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Another huge fan.
You got me through my
pregnancy, and recovery,
and the last eight years.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Just thank you,
thank you, thank you so much.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I travel
a lot for work
and I oftentimes
find myself booking
hotels that are closer
to Flywheel locations,
because I know that even in
the change of my routine,
I still get the experience
I want in cardio.
And we still feel like
New York and the energy
you need for the day.
Can you talk a little bit about
how the expansion strategy
worked with also
making sure that you
had the same culture, and
energy, and type of trainers?
They do differ a bit
location to location.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But how you keep
the consistency of the brand
with such a massive expansion.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So I'm
not going to lie--
and you actually
just pointed it out--
when the expansion got to a
certain point and it was really
big, it was hard--
it's hard to
maintain the culture.
And up until a certain point,
we were able to maintain it.
And I really feel
like that change
happened when we were taken
over and when we were acquired.
At that point, we had 22
studios, which is still a lot.
And I always say this,
it's not rocket science.
My partner and I--
Jay-- our third partner stayed
in the background and did more
real estate and finance--
but Jay and I were
in the forefront.
And I was the face and
Jay was in operations
and really ran the business.
And as simple as this
sounds, Jay and I
are both very nice people.
And unfortunately, we both had
this quality where we really
need to be liked by
everybody, which is not always
a really great quality.
But we both had it.
And so there's
such a trickle down
phenomenon that
happens from the top.
And as a result, we just amassed
this amazing group of people.
And it also had a lot to do with
how we treated our employees.
And we considered
our employees to be
as important as our customers.
And it didn't matter
what your role was.
It didn't matter if
you were mopping floors
or you were a senior VP,
everybody was treated the same.
And I think that because
of that, we just ended up--
really great, nice, wonderful
people gravitated to us
and wanted to work with us.
And that's why we
would always call it
the Fly family, the Fly fam,
because we all really felt
like a family.
But no question, as we expanded
and the expansion continued--
that's what I talked
about before--
where that specialness
kind of was compromised.
AUDIENCE: I also love studying
all things fitness trends.
So love that you're
into that as well.
What are some of the studios
or concepts or things
that you're really looking at
that are doing it right now?
And as you're thinking
about your future, what
insights do you think you'd
want to take from them?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So it's
interesting because when I hear
about other successful
boutique fitness businesses--
we were talking about
Rumble, for example--
the ones that I hear a
lot of excitement about
are, again, the ones where
people are gravitating
toward the community.
And so I've heard that
a lot about Rumble.
And there was actually a
really interesting article--
I don't know if
you guys saw it--
that came out recently in Vox.
And the writer talked about
this concept of expansion.
She talks a lot about
Flywheel and SoulCycle.
And her opinion was that they
lost their focus and identity.
And she spent a lot of
time talking about boutique
and how the smaller studios
that are coming up now
are actually doing better and
people are going back to that.
And so I found that really
interesting in terms of trends
and things going full circle.
But I hear a lot about Rumble.
Boxing seems to
really be taking on.
I do feel that
things have changed
so much since the days of
SoulCycle starting and Flywheel
starting.
And I'm about to lose
my train of thought--
I know-- and so what's
been happening-- again,
the whole full circle thing
is-- a lot of these boutique
businesses that started
out as boutique,
have now expanded
their modalities.
And a Flywheel or
a SoulCycle started
adding a lot of different
kinds of classes.
And now we see a
lot of these studios
with five different offerings.
And in a sense, that
feels to me like,
oh, so what started as a very
dedicated boutique business
has now actually
morphed into the big box
Jim, which is how we
started in the first place.
So if I were to start again--
spoiler alert-- and I haven't
committed to anything.
But I think that if I did
do another brick and mortar,
it would never be about
one offering, which is what
it could be about initially.
But I'd probably have
two and that would be it.
I wouldn't want to make
it any bigger than that.
And as I said before, I think
that the community aspect
and the connecting
with people is never
going to fall out of favor.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I read
that article too.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I read the
Vox article, too.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Right.
I thought it was interesting.
And it made me look really
good, so I liked that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you
for making an
Android app finally.
That was awesome.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One is, what is your
personal fitness routine?
Are you still spinning?
Do you teach?
And my second
question is, there's
a lot of new trends in
terms of virtual reality
where bikes are actually moving
in the rooms or music videos.
Do you think those are
all gimmicks or are they
actually contributing
something to the experience?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: So it's
hard to answer that
without my own personal opinion.
For myself, they do
seem gimmicky to me.
It's just my opinion.
As I said, I left
Flywheel December 31.
But up until December 31, I was
teaching six to seven classes
a week.
I can't ever imagine
not teaching.
It's just what I do.
And I love it and
it never gets old.
And as I was saying to
Charity, I've been teaching--
I've been on a
bike for 21 years.
Sadly, I hate to
even talk about this,
but I am nursing a
back injury right now--
a lower back injury.
So for the first time in
21 years, I'm off the bike
and I'm not doing
anything except going
to physical therapy.
So it'll be interesting
to see if anything
changes being off the bike.
I mean, I think one
of the reasons why
I've been such an
advocate for spinning
is that it's actually so
safe and it's low impact.
And people can do it at any age.
So whatever is
going on in my back,
maybe it's overuse and just
long-term kind of situation.
Hopefully, it will
get better soon.
But at the same time,
I am an advocate
to mixing it up and not
just doing one modality.
I was doing SLT for awhile.
And I enjoyed that.
It's so challenging.
And then of late, I've
been incorporating Pilates
into my routine, because I
think Pilates is so challenging,
but really effective.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
ask about the book, which
is your newest baby.
And what I'm fascinated
by is, obviously, you've
left an amazing legacy.
But also, as a
business woman who's
done very well, as you were
thinking about the book and all
the many things you
can write about--
and I'm sure you had an eye
on the business aspect of what
is the most
interesting, how do you
get the most viewers and
readers and what not.
How did you decide what
to cover in the book
and what to emphasize on
and how to position it?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: The beginning--
sorry-- the genesis
of the book really
happened by me just
sitting down and starting
to write personal anecdotes.
That's how I started it.
I worked with a collaborator,
because I really
didn't know how to start.
And she posed that to me.
She said, what about
sitting down and writing
10 stories that come to
mind through the course
of your life.
And so that's how I started.
And so it really started I
think from a personal place,
and then I was quickly
able to draw lessons
from personal experiences,
lessons that I learned in life,
and then applied
them to business.
So that's kind of how
that theme happened.
And it really came--
the whole idea to
do it that way just
happened really organically
and really easily.
And again, it was very
consistent with me
because I am all
about not being afraid
of sharing personal
stories, and that's
how I connect with people.
So it just made sense.
AUDIENCE: So it was more organic
versus like a market research.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Absolutely.
Much more organic, which
again, made sense for me
since no business experience.
AUDIENCE: And I know I
have another question.
I just wanted to say,
you look amazing.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
start spinning again.
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I have to say,
I was a little disappointed,
because usually it comes
out in my talks that I'm 60,
and it usually gets
a huge response.
And all of you guys were
like, yeah, whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
So thank you.
CHARITY WORRELL: Are
there any more questions?
Oh, here we are.
AUDIENCE: I'm also
nursing an injury
and I'm a big time
runner, so I sympathize--
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: --with how
terrible and disruptive
it is with your life.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: It's the worst.
AUDIENCE: I was in Pilates
and PT, so I understand.
But I wanted to learn
a little bit more
about the marketing aspect
of the Flywheel brand.
I'm in ad sales here at Google.
And I always think
it's interesting,
especially in a super
competitive environment
like fitness, especially
with the rise of social media
and just all of the
community aspects of it.
But how do you still make paid
advertising and paid marketing
really work for your brand
and actually drive results?
So I'd love to hear
more about that.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Sure.
So we never advertised, ever.
This business was so word of
mouth that we never needed to.
Things have changed now.
And it's interesting--
marketing and branding--
I remember specifically
when we started Flywheel,
we really had no idea what our
brand was going to look like.
And people would say,
well, what's your brand?
And my partner and I
would say, we don't know.
And we just started the
business and the brand
came to us through
trial and error.
And it was just a way to
figure out who we were.
And then we actually
hired a marketing team
to work with us about a year in.
And they were the ones who came
up with the idea of never coast
and we loved that.
And so that really became
a game-changer for us.
And that was something we could
really hang on to and build
a marketing plan from.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have a
question about the pricing
and how you came up with
that, because SoulCycle to me
seems like one of the
first kind of boutique,
or the most well-known
early boutique places.
And I was wondering how you
guys came up with the pricing
strategy and having no
memberships and stuff
like this at a gym.
And then if it was
a conscious decision
to change your mind
when going to Flywheel.
I'm just basically
wondering how did
you know that people
were going to want
to pay this type of money to
do a boutique fitness class,
because it doesn't really seem
like people were doing that
before.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Purely ripped
it off from SoulCycle.
We did.
I mean, we just used--
looked at their model as to how
they priced and replicated it.
We knew that they
were getting it,
because the business was booming
at that point when I left.
And so that's how we did it.
However, over time we
changed our strategy,
because they became through
their pricing even more
elitist.
And we really wanted
to move away from that.
I mean, they offered
their Super Soul for $70
for a 45-minute spin class.
And that just wasn't us.
It wasn't our identity.
And we really wanted to
build a business that
was about inclusiveness,
and SoulCycle to us
seemed like a business that
was about exclusiveness.
So that was very important in
how we went about our pricing.
I personally was not in charge
of that part of the business,
so I can't speak with
too much detail about it.
But I know that the membership
idea really took off for us
and people loved membership,
because they could really
get in a lot of classes
for a lot less money.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: You're welcome.
CHARITY WORRELL: What I do love
is that you give the spin shoes
for free rental, whereas
SoulCycle I think
goes like $3 or $4.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Yeah, and water.
Paid for water as well.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Yeah, which is great,
because you don't
have to bring anything
with you, which is amazing.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: And
that was another way
in which we started the
business and figured out
things was, obviously, I was
coming from SoulCycle and so
what better way than for me
to look back on SoulCycle
and know what worked
and what didn't work.
And the things that
worked, we kept.
didn't work, we changed.
And one of the things I knew
from the rider experience
was they would come to
take class and then,
oh, they'd have to take
out their wallet again
to pay for water or take out
their wallet to pay for shoes.
And they really
kind of resented it.
So that was just
one example of how
we thought we are going
to do away with that.
CHARITY WORRELL:
One last question.
AUDIENCE: I think I have
a good last question.
So we have a spin studio
on the 14th floor.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I saw it.
AUDIENCE: Once
your back gets back
in order, what are the
chances you come and teach us?
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I was
actually thinking about that.
I really was.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: We can help organize.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I'll do it.
Yeah.
I'll do it.
AUDIENCE: Yay!
CHARITY WORRELL: Woo-hoo!
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Now I'm actually
wondering if that would
interfere with my non-compete.
But I mean, come on.
AUDIENCE: We won't tell anyone.
RUTH ZUKERMAN:
Don't tell anyone.
Yeah, that'll work.
CHARITY WORRELL: Because I
never got to take your class.
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH ZUKERMAN: I
would love to do it.
Thank you for inviting me.
CHARITY WORRELL:
And Ruth will be
upstairs to sign books after.
So if everyone wants
to queue upstairs,
she'll be signing things
and you can buy the book.
And thank you so
much for coming.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: You're welcome.
CHARITY WORRELL: It was
such a pleasure meeting you.
RUTH ZUKERMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]